Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario Maker
Now, I have skipped the last one
Because that one was *Mario shrinks* Ugh, God
Wh—Why?
Why?
Whyyyyy?
This seems like actually,
This seems ridiculously similar to
an actual
level of Mario Maker—Err—Mario
Super Mario
Soo-Smar Smar Smar Smario's Smooper Maker
Smoo-Smooper's Mario?
MmSmros?
Sma-Smee-Shmeper, Shmeper Shmoper Shmrose
This seems very muuuuch liiiiike thaaaat shiiiiit
My dick
Oh, God Whyyy
Okay!
Oh hi, Chica!
Things are going badly
As per usually
Chica's just like
"Hey, what else is new, dad?
You're terrible at this." (good point there)
(Back to Mark) I know!
I played live on the Grump Show, I did, they pulled me on stage
With very minimal warning
I wasn't told before it that I was doing any—it was just like
Danny came up and was like
"Hey, you want to be on stage?", and I'm like
"I don't know what I'm doin'.
Okay, I guess."
I could jump over these,
But I'm gonna take my time because patience is key
On everything that I do in this
And what I normally not do with the patience doing
I usually done did end up me deadnens ness...
Heeeeehhh
Please be mushroom because I keep losing my chances
No, I'm not gonna go down there just yet.
I know better.
I'm smart doing the thing that's smart
ehh
Get outta here
No, WHAAOH Oh God
Ok. Nope.
Yeah, I'm gonna dodge you
Dodge like that. Ok.
Oh God noo not what I wanted, lost it again
Why did I lose it again? Okay, we're fine.
Ok
Heeeeeh
Oh, boy, another one, they're giving me so many chances
They really shouldn't
I'm not—I don't deserve this.
In any way. Oh, look, another chance. Oh, good.
Oh, it's tons of chances!
Oh, it's unlimited chanceors
Hello!
Hi!
What do I do about you?
Ok
Oh, I know what I do
I gotta, ohhh, I see
it's one of these things
Ok, I gotta get you to press the blook
Come on down here, buddy
Hoooo
Oh, God I'm shaking in my boots
Blehf
This is gonna take awhile
Bowser: It will take ages cause you suck!
wup!
Aw, come on.
Ah! No! I forgot it was doing thaaaaaaaat!
Aw, come on, I forgot!
How did I forget that that was happening?
How did I forget what was going on?
What is wrong with me?
Alright, fine, we're gonna get through this
all
Au Naturale
Fuuuck again with the bullshit
Aw, goddamn it, my...
(It slowly dawns on mark that bowser was right)
(Mark regrets life choices, but disguises it with laughter)
Why did I say I was going to get through this (starts to regret even more)
Au Naturale?
That means
Doesn't that mean I'm gonna do this naked?
And I don't think that's what I want to do...
AHHHHH FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU MAN!
(Sad chuckle) Fuuuck yoouu....
(Cries like wee babe) IIIII am not having a good tiiime...
I—WAAHHH FUCK YOUAA—
It's always... it's always the first try that I go through these
Bad boys
that
things go well for me
and they—God, again with the bullfliplth?
(with lisp) Thiths Bullthipth is gettin' me baaad.
ugghh thaths suchth bullshithth
(Scream of a dying goat)
FUCK OOOFFFFFF!
(To Chica) Chica, it's okay....
I'm not yelling at you, I promise!
I promise I'm not...
I'm doing very poorly on my life...
M—My life choices, and life utilization...
I'm not...
I'm—I'm not even half-way through
I'm not half-way through
I gotta get half-way through!
or else i'm gonna go nowhere with my life
[manly mating call]
FUCK! [more manly mating call]
--hack! Oh man!
I can't do this, I can't do this [yes you can]
I can't
Well I'm not saying I can't do what's in front of me
I can't do this stupid playing that I'm doing [good point there x2]
The-The be stupidness
That's-That's what i'm trying to actively avoid
The be stupiding
*Markiplier exhales* hurhhhhhh
*Old man's voice* why am i such a stupid----
Why am i such a SUCK?!
Hookay. Everything's fine...
*Markiplier painful moan* AHHHHHHHHH
F-YOU AND YOUR FUK----
GOD DAMMIIIIIIT
*Markiplier painful moan* urhhhhhh
Uh
Okay
*Pants pants pants*
*Chuckles*
I think---What's over here?
Is there anything? No it's nothin'...
Okay
They're gonna give me another chance after I get through here. I just have to get through here
And then eventually they're gonna give me another chance
Once I take my god damn time with this....shiet
And... ya know, enjoy life?!
Smell the roses.... All that bullshit
Ah shit
Ah shit dude
HEH!
HOHOH
HOHOH!
HEH!
*Chuckles* I wasn't patient
I know
Every time i do this i get finicky and unpatientness....ness
(Markiplier Vocabulary)
I get antipatient and then I-It ends up biting me in the choooode
*Markiplier whispers* It's okay...
It's okay though....
I know....
Hup!
Haha!
Hoho!
Heehee!
Haha!
Huhu!
What's up there?
There's something up there
I'm gonna find it!
I'm gonna get it!
What's up here?
OOOOh it's a 1-UP!
Do I need this? Probably not
Actually absolutely I do considering my poor record of...
Mario Utilizations
Man, 40-something clones are already down the...
Wind---Pipe
Somethin' like dat, I dunno...
Okay this time i'm not gonna be a SUCK!
Guhbub!
EEEEEEEERHH!
Okay, that's where you're gonna be huh?
Do it
Do somethin'
No balls?
AHHH!
Won't do it again?
Woh! Ah god dammit!
No balls! No balls! I got no balls!
Cuz I got no shruum!
No balls! No balls!
No balls!
You got no balls!
Huh? You won't come after me bruh?
Yer no balls!
Woh okay that's not where I expected you to go
Ah I'll take it!
No balls?
No balls? No balls?
Won't do it?
You won't do it!
you won't do it!
You won't do it! won't do it!
Can't do it!
What you gonna do?
Nothin? Huh?
Hup!
HAAAA!!!
Oooooh!
I dids it!
Oh okay. I know what I need to do
Hah!
No balls?
No piranha pants?
No pirahna--oh FUCK
Godammit!
Right at the last goddamn second---YES
Okay!
I was right there! If I'd had just done it the first time around I would've been way better
off but I just sucked all over it
I sucked it so hard
I just suck---sucked it up
I sucked it all up
[Weird eating noises]
I drank its milkshake out of its balls!
Okay anyway
MOVIN' ON! Movin' on. Movin' on. Movin' on.
We got more to do. We got more to win. We got more things to do.
I've totally I'd forgotten that I'd been on camera this whole time
So I don't know what horrible horrible things I might have said.
or done *Chuckles* oh God what is this asshole?
What is this assmess?
What is this ass?
Oh god I forgot that I don't pick him up in this one
okay
So the objective is to not touch
As many of these as possible
Oh shit
I did exactly that.
I did exactly the thing I wasn't supposed to do
But there's a there's a mushroom in there
that's a checkpoint
Okay
This is crazy
But I got it
Watch this
It's cool
Everybody it's cool
Okay
What
I don't know how I stopped that
Ah dammit! Oh dim dam
Dim dam the flim flam
Goddammit with the dim dam the flim flam
Stop--Just stop--STOP!!
Uh! Ooh! Ah! Okay
Sick moves I'm gonna plan like I did that on purpose
FUUUCK
Again with this bullshit! Oh don't rush
No time to rush
Hooo god
Oh gaersh
okay
Did that again
[gibberish] FUUUCK
Everytime!
Every goddamn time
every tim tam time
every frick fack time-YES
J-JUST YEAH, YEAHHHHH
Wooh!
That was a bitch!
Hoo but i did it!
*exhales*
Okay, i can do another
I can-I can do one more
i can do one more...
Man, i bet the world record is someone going above it all
because i didn't go up
i stayed down on the ground floor where it was safe
*Mark reading the title*
Oh boy this doesn't sound good...
Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-Ha-He-Hi-Hu-Ha-Hi-Hu-ha
*Markiplier realizes* Oooooh i get it i gotta try to hit the POW!
Boink!
*Markiplier high pitch* Boink!
Ah that was easy. Goooot it. I like this!
If this isn't like this the whole time....
Boink!
Oh it's Brick Breaker!
Someone made Brick Breaker in this shit?! (Apparently :D)
What the hell?! That's so cool!
How in the hell did they do that?!
Okay, this is a welcome change from everything
else that was going on
This is AWESOME! :D
OOOH! It's so cool
If i can just hit it properly...
Dammit!
There we go
Hip!
Hiep!
That's so cool. That is SO COOL
(Space is cool anyone?)
So well made too! Like, just a creative idea
I've been watching the Game Grumps play Super Mario Maker all the time
...Cuz I watch the Game Grumps play all the time anyway
So, it's-it's literally all i do but
MAN that's so cool
NO!!
Ohoh god they *wut*
They put---Oh wow they knew someone is gonna be so stupid
(namely Mark XD)
Oh they knew!
.....Oh they knew.....
Hoo thanks goodness they knew----Am i supposed to-----
Ohhh~
Oh that's gonna be....
Oh that's gonna be impossible
God dammit
Oh that's gonna be impossible....
How--- I'm not supposed to be carrying this----
Oh I'll take this!
*Markiplier high pitch* YAAAAY!
Maybe if I.....This is  a way?
EEEEEE
Naw just barely not enough...
But I could probably get a head start....
Woh
Oh
Uza Uza Uza Uzaa... Huz za smart man?
UZA SMART MAN?!
Uza....I'm getting fubbernucked----
Ohoh god!
I'm gettin' beaten and backed out----THERE WE GO!
YEAH! I'M SO HAPPY :D
Oh this is a---HELLO!
Big boot of LOVE ♥
AH this is perfect
Hit. Hit? What does that mean?
Do i get like ground---
Oh yeah i forget you can ground stomp in this
Okay! I can do this
*Self compliments* Smart idea XD
AHH tities.
Gotta time it on the top one...
Ahh dammit!
This is gonna take a while!